[Music]
netflix's library is so vast that it's
often tough to figure out what to watch
luckily if you know what to look for
you're bound to find a few stone cold
classics
from underrated gems to timeless
favorites these are the best movies on
netflix right now
over the past decade a24 films has
transformed itself from the little indie
studio that could into a bonafide
powerhouse one that regularly challenges
big time studios for box office
supremacy
and award season glory they've done so
by continuing to release a near
immaculate
later films that vary from high-minded
genre fair to complex human dramas and
comedies
and pretty much everything in between
2016 was the year a24 became a legit
player in hollywood
and not coincidentally it was also the
year the studio released the barry
jenkins heartfelt and harrowing coming
of age drama
moonlight this film cleaned up at the
box office blew the critics away
and stormed the oscars by claiming three
academy awards
including best picture much has already
been said about moonlight's dramatic
virtue
and brilliant artistic integrity but you
really can't downplay just how good this
movie is
a number of pitch perfect performances
the stylistic mix of naturalistic and
expressionistic photography
and an awe-inspiring original score make
moonlight every bit the immaculate human
drama
you've heard so much about if you've yet
to experience it for yourself then don't
wait around because there's really no
better time to bask in the lush and
lavish glow of moonlight in 2015
justin benson and aaron morehead teamed
up to release spring
a wildly innovative lovecraftian romance
about a young man falling in love with a
mysterious woman
or traveling in europe despite scoring
well with critics however
not many people actually saw it those
who did likely discovered spring on
netflix
where the film eventually garnered its
well-deserved status as a cult classic
fans of spring knew full well what
benson and morehead could do
and so they anxiously awaited the pair's
next offering then in 2017
they released the endless another
critically acclaimed genre mashup that
follows a similarly grounded dramatic
approach to horror and sci-fi filmmaking
in the endless benson and morehead spin
a complex tale of two brothers who make
the fateful decision to revisit the
alien death calls they have managed to
escape in their youth
and that's about all you need to know
going in because part of the endless
narrative magic
is found in uncovering the film's
unnerving existential mysteries for
yourself
saying more to be like trying to explain
an impossible color
it's a mind-bending trip into the
unknown and by the end you'll be sure of
just one thing
that benson and morehead are two of the
most daring cold filmmakers of their
generation
few names in the history of cinema
inspire as much aura and respect as
martin scorsese
now in the fifth decade of his all but
an impeachable career score says he has
somehow managed to maintain his fiercely
independent vision
while cranking out more genuine
cinematic masterpieces than
well pretty much any filmmaker who's
ever lived the irish murder squad says
he's 26th feature film
and it's certain to go down as one of
his late game masterworks
at three and a half hours the irishman
is also the longest film of scorsese's
career
shockingly however it seems a film
almost never happened since most studios
apparently weren't interested in
financing a new scorecity film
with robert de niro in the lead luckily
netflix jumped at the chance to add the
latest martin scorsetti picture to their
in-house catalogue
anchored by a powerhouse turn from de
niro the irishman finds the legendary
director in surprisingly subtle form
delivering a melancholic slow burner of
a gangster flick curled from a real-life
story about ruthless mobsters
fractured families violence and betrayal
yes the irishman might look like a
typical martin scorsese gangster flick
but rest assured it's anything but if
nothing else the irish money is emphatic
proof that even 50 years into his career
scorsese still has a few tricks up his
sleeve yes it seems like netflix ought
to be the streaming service of choice
for scorsese fans
although today is a cinematic icon back
in 1976
school said he was still a brash young
director who had only just become known
as an up-and-comer but taxi driver is a
film that formally announced
a rival in hollywood positing the
director as both a radical cinematic
stylist
and a leading voice in 20th century
cinema oh and it's also the movie that
established robert de niro as a once in
a generation acting talent
saw a baby face jody foster step into
the spotlight and heralded the now
legendary scribe paul schrader
as one of the best writers in the
industry it also proved a hit with
critics
scored respectable numbers at the box
office and earned a handful of oscar
nominations to boot
today taxi driver is considered one of
the most important films ever produced
and it's more than worthy of that price
the movie's politically charged
narrative feels as vital in today's
climate as it likely did upon release
and the technical skill behind the
production is nothing less than
jaw-dropping
put sure to taxi driver is essential
viewing for anyone who loves movies
the lobster is revealed to doubt one of
the weirdest movies ever made
it's also one of the funniest most
emotionally devastating movies you'll
ever see
and certainly the funniest and most
devastating movie you'll ever see
about people desperately searching for
love to avoid being turned into an
animal
yep you heard that right the lobster
takes place in a dystopian near future
in which single people are rounded up
and given 45 days
to find true love or be turned into an
animal of their choosing
and released into the wild so yeah it's
pretty weird but the lobster is also a
cinematic experience unlike any other
colin farrell and rachel vise both
deliver career best performances
the script is outright hilarious and the
whole thing somehow comes off as
incredibly human and romantic
even though it often feels like it's
totally devoid of either romance or
humanity
the lobster is like nothing else out
there in the best possible way
the death of stalin is a savage witty
and outlandish comedy
one that continues to beat out the
competition years after it left theatres
written and directed by the legendary
satirist amando iannucci the death of
stalin takes a joyously off-the-wall
approach to one of the most deadly
periods in the history of the soviet
union
the movie is led by a stellar cast
including steve buscemi
jeffrey tambor and jason isaacs and
thanks in part to an immaculate script
it perfectly captures the horror and
absurdity of life under a totalitarian
regime
special consideration also has to be
given to the movie's superb bombastic
score
and a downright terrifying performance
from simon russell beal
who plays one of the most unsettling
movie villains of the last decade
you have a nice long sleep armor
i'll take it from me best of all however
the death of stalin is so jam-packed
with subtle gags
and witty one-liners that you're bound
to enjoy it just as much on the second
third or even fourth viewing and with
every new watch
the film's utterly absorbing and mile a
minute narrative carries as much
dramatic weight as it does on the first
hopefully you've seen at least one of
jungim's wushu's wonders over the years
but if you're looking for a gateway into
the martial arts director's fantastical
cinematic over
then look no further than the director's
tragically overlooked masterpiece
2019's shadow set drawing china's three
kingdoms era
shadow follows a tale of an impetuous
king a brilliant commander his so-called
life shadow
and a pair of noble women searching for
their rightful place in a war-torn world
that has little room for them
and then at the center of it all is a
vicious battle over a hugely important
ward city
that's basically all you need to know
about shadow's plot because the plot
isn't really the plot more than anything
you're better off just sitting back and
marveling at the films or inspired
photography
mind-boggling set pieces and sweeping
musical flourishes
and hey if you get swept up in the
film's incredible almost shakespearean
narrative twist along the way
well all the better though he's been
working behind the camera for over 20
years
paul thomas anderson has made just eight
feature films in that time
and while his fans might argue endlessly
over which of his movies is best
anderson himself appears to have no
trouble choosing his favorite
no it's not boogie nights or phantom
thread or even there will be blood
in fact pta's favorite pta movie is a
brilliant and
often overlooked 2012 cult drama the
master
but although the master is criminally
underrated compared to the maestro's
other works there really is a lot to
love in this haunting and emotionally
raw character study the film follows for
keen phoenix's scarred and unstable
world war ii vet
freddy as he drifts aimlessly through
his post-war life fortunes seem to
change for freddie when he meets a
charismatic guru played by the late
philip seymour hoffman who was
spearheading his own spiritual movement
from there anderson and company guide
the master through a twisted tale of
fractured humanity
and shifting power dynamics that teeters
effortlessly between the weird the
sexual the horrific
and the metaphysical in the mix anderson
draws korea best work from his curse
and delivers a film more than worthy of
adoration from the man who conjured it
few actors have cast as long as shadow
over their craft as daniel day-lewis
thanks to his fierce dedication to
method acting and his uncanny ability to
transform himself body and soul for each
new role
he's become one of the most critically
acclaimed and famous actors in recent
cinema history
day lewis claimed his second of three
best actor award for his towering work
as there will be blood's ruthless turn
of the century oilman
and frankly merely calling day lewis's
performance and there will be blood
towering seems like an understatement
because paul thomas anderson's film is
utterly consumed by day lewis's presence
the beloved actors near mythic work in
this movie is so utterly transfixing
it's almost easy to lose sight of
anderson's own mastery throughout
still even as the preeta naturally
gifted filmmaker willfully puts his
actor's scene devouring turn front and
center he wisely uses it to bolster
what's essentially an epic chamber drama
about capitalism run amok this movie is
as audaciously ambitious as it is
inherently insightful
and may just feature the best work to
date from both actor and director
over the past few years netflix has
transformed itself from a streaming
service that produces small-scale
passion projects
into a legit industry powerhouse one
whose artist friendly approach has drawn
talents like the coen brothers
alfonso cuaron and steven soderbergh
into the fold
along the way it has become a regular
awards season player even making a
splash at the oscars in recent years
case in point nova bound back's
harrowing relationship dramady marriage
story which was nominated in six
categories at the academy awards
including four out of the so-called big
five best picture
best actor best actress and best
original screenplay
in the end it took home one statue best
supporting actress for laura dern
baumbach's latest picture also led the
pack in terms of nominations at the 2020
golden globes with adam driver and
scarlett johansson both
landing nods for their performances and
yes the duo more than earns the praise
they've been receiving ever since
marriage story made its debut on netflix
curious to see what the first is all
about give it a go and find out
would the tutorial would the twice the
same keep your head still was it a twist
or something
would that it was the same i'm trying to
say that mr lawrence
since bursting onto the scene with
1984's neo nawaz on a blood simple
joel and ethan cohen have become poster
boys for the hollywood outsider who have
made it big in showbiz
earning a handful of oscars and waves of
critical praise to boot they've also
brought their singular wit and audacious
cinematic vision to pretty much every
genre under the sun
quite often the coen brothers have
packed several seemingly disparate
genres into the same film
essentially concocting their own
entirely new genres and the process
but the cohen's uncanny pension for
genre gymnastics has never been so on
display as it is in their immaculate
skewering of hollywood's golden age hail
caesar
what did it
set largely on the backlot of a 1950s
movie studio
the movie mainly follows a fixer played
by josh brolin who goes above and beyond
and keeping the studios multiple stars
directors and productions in check hail
caesar finds the comments packing
literal representations of every genre
they can get their hands on
into a darkly comical overarching
narrative about cold war anxieties in
mid-century america
while that everything at once approach
occasionally leaves hail caesar feeling
a bit unfocused
it still offers ample opportunity for
the brothers to show off their razor
sharp writing
and their impeccable taste in actors and
though hail caesar ranks among the
slighter of the cohen's efforts it also
remains one of their most misunderstood
and to some fans even one of their best
you could say helpful circle what
they're doing
what did it was were you doing this one
twice
after his debut with 2011's marvelously
twisted horror kill list
ben wheatley has crafted one of the more
colorful resumes in show business
he followed his breakout with a psycho
killer romantic romp
cycius the psychedelic period horror
afield in england
and the stunning socially conscious
satire that is 2015's high rise
with such a wildly varied slate of films
keeping its fans decidedly off balance
wheatley followed the success of
highrise by once again switching speeds
with 2016's action-packed crackerjack
crime fast
free fire undoubtedly his highest
profile film to date
wheatley had no doubt earn the right to
indulge himself with a little bombast
but free fire went big in totally
unexpected ways
in fact with free fire wheatley went
pretty much off the wall nuts
casting an impressive slate of actors
and throwing them into a viper pit of a
narrative
in ways that really have to be seen to
be believed following an arms deal gone
wrong
the entirety of free fires 90 minute run
time and falls in real time in just a
single location
and is mostly taken up by a single epic
gun battle with whole crates of
artillery and ammunition to hand that
fight is every bit as wild as you'd hope
and makes for one of the more
deliriously brutal stylish
and funny cinematic releases of the last
few years
though a recent string of critically
acclaimed releases has helped reshape
the conversation
surrounding horror movies the genre on
the whole continues to be viewed as
slight and schlocky by snobby cinephiles
or world over
of course many of those same snobs are
quick to hail jonathan demi's 1991 best
picture winner the silence of the lambs
as a masterpiece
even while refusing to acknowledge it as
a horror movie at all but make no
mistake this is a horror movie to its
very core
a census taker once tried to test me
i ate his liver with some fava beans
and a nice chianti you've probably at
least heard of the silence of the lambs
because its cinematic legacy is pretty
much unimpeachable
in case you don't know the film follows
an fbi agent cadet who becomes ensnared
in a manhunt for a sadistic killer
to find her murderer she turns to
hannibal lecter a brilliant psychologist
in prison for killing and eating his own
patience
as the action unfolds so too does the
horror with demi crafting an enthralling
crime thriller packed with more gore
jumpscares and boogeymen than your
average slasher flick
and doing so with the grace and vitality
of a bonafide cinematic master
perhaps more than any other filmmaker in
history spike lee continues to elicit a
decidedly visceral reaction from
moviegoers
that's very much by design too as these
films are specifically meant to not just
push buttons
but to push viewers as far out of their
emotional comfort zones as possible
and whether you love or loathe what
spike lee brings to cinema
few can argue his uncompromising
cinematic artistry or his indefatigable
flair for biting social drama
given the state of the world it should
come as no surprise that lee is pushing
boundaries further than ever he made
serious waves with a searing racially
charged 2018 thriller black clansmen
and lee got back in the saddle in 2015
with the fevered vietnam war drama the
five bloods
lee's latest follows a group of vietnam
vets who find themselves back in the
country decades after the war's end to
bring home the remains of their fallen
brother
and the cash of gold they'd stored away
during combat equal parts anti-war drama
and action-packed treasure hunt
adventure
the five bloods explores these men in
both timelines as they struggle with
fighting a war for a country that
even decades later all but refuses to
recognize their sacrifice
yes the five bloods is as politically
and socially motivated as any film
spyclear's ever made
and it's also a daring devastating
document of the black experience that
frankly
demands to be seen by as many folks as
possible the last half decade hasn't
exactly been one to remember for johnny
depp
it hasn't been a banner few years for
his frequent collaborator tim burton
either
but no matter how far the duo's legacies
might have slipped of late
they're still likely to go down as one
of the most creatively congruous
director actor combos in movie history
that statement would ring true even if
you accounted for depths and burton's
collaborations in the 90s alone
they kicked off the decade with the
inimatic suburban satire edward
scissorhands following it up with a
lovingly twisted biographical dramedy ed
wood
and then close the decade out with what
might be the most underrated example of
their shared cinematic talents this was
1999 sleepy hollow
which found both actor and director
delivering a bold reimagining of
washington irving's iconic tale of
terror the legend of sleepy hollow
perhaps better known as the tale of the
headless horseman
in the hands of burton and depp that
classic story becomes a hyper stylized
steampunk nightmare
one that transforms the cowardly ichabod
crane into a cunning turn of the century
constable who was dispatched to the
titular town to solve a series of grisly
murders
in which victims are left without their
heads yes this story is exactly as
thrilling
gory and glorious as you might think and
even if you are familiar with the
well-trod lore behind sleepy hollow
it's a surefire guarantee that you've
never before seen it told quite like
this
for film fans of a certain temperament
charlie kaufman's name elicits pangs of
pure cinematic bliss
luckily for them his latest movie
debuted on netflix in the waning days of
summer 2020.
for those new to charlie kaufman's work
you probably ought to know that you're
entering a world rife with emotional
turmoil tragically flawed characters
and wild metaphysical quandaries
kaufman's movies also burst at the scene
with rapturous and often soul-crushing
humanity
and the writer-director's new film i'm
thinking of ending things
is as twisted and soulful as anything
he's ever done it's difficult to explain
what i'm thinking of ending things as
about
because kaufman's latest is quite
literally about everything
the film follows a young woman hitting
the road with her newish partner to meet
his parents for the first time and from
that deceptively simple setup
kaufman delivers a stylishly ambitious
emotionally raw cinematic odyssey that's
wonderfully weird and esoterically eerie
in ways you just have to see to believe
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one